ولا تزال التداعيات مستمره والحديث هنا عن
امرين كلاهما صادم اكثر من الاخر الاول
كشفت عنه وكاله اسوشيتد بريس بالصوت
والصوره ويتمثل في وجود شبكه سجون سريه في
اليمن تديرها دوله الامارات ويخضع فيها
المعتقلون لصنوف مختلفه من التعذيب الثاني
جاء في تقرير لمنظمه هيومان رايتس وتش
يقول ان دوله الامارات تقدم الدعم لقوات
يمنيه احتجزت تعسفا عشرات الاشخاص واخفت
قصرا ابو ظبي تنفي لكن مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي يريد اجابات عن اسئله كثيره
والعفو الدوليه تقول انه سيعلن عن تحقيق
تشرف عليه الامم المتحده مباشره مريم
اوباييش ترصد التفاصيل في هذا
التقرير الفتره هذا 177 يوم ونحن في ضرب
وشتيمه وفي
اهانه في من ضمن التعديب اللي يعدمون نحنا
في دكتور يسمونه الدكتور الاماراتي فضيحه
السجون السريه الاماراتيه في اليمن الملف
الذي فتحته هيومان رايتس واتش ووكاله
اسوشيتد بريس لن يغلقه نفي حكومه ابو ظبي
لقصص التعذيب المروعه المتهمه بها ومنها
تهمه شي السجناء على النار حتى مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي يريد اجابات عن اسئله
كثيره فقد طالبت لجنه الخدمات المسلحه في
المجلس من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اجراء
تحقيق فوري لك كشف الحقائق عن الاتهامات
بالمعامله السيئه والدعم الامريكي للقوات
الاماراتيه واليمنيه المشاركه في عملي
التعذيب وضمن ردود الفعل على التقرير
الصادم دعوه منظمه العفو الدوليه الى
اجراء تحقيق عاجل بشان اداره الامارات
وقوات يمنيه تحت امرتها شبكه من السجون
السريه في جنوب اليمن وفق مديره البحث في
المنظمه سيعلن عن تحقيق تشرف عليه الامم
المتحده مباشره يتعلق التحقيق بدور
الامارات العربيه والاطراف الاخرى التي
اقامت شبكه سجون مروعه للتعذيب ادت الى
اختفاء الاف اليمنيين من هنا مر بعضهم
وهنا مرست ابشع اساليب التعذيب استنادا
لشهادات معتقلين سابقين لوكاله اي بي
شهادات كثيره ربما لن يكشف عنها لان
اصحابها فرقوا الحياه تحت التعذيب ولا
يعرف مصير جثثهم
وثقت وكاله اي بي ما لا يقل عن 18 سجنا
سريا في جنوب اليمن تحت اداره اماراتيه
يضيف التقرير ان تلك السجون مخفيه داخل
قواعد عسكريه وموانئ وفي احد المطارات
وكذلك في فيلات وحتى في ملهى الليلي ثمت
ايضا اتهامات بنقل بعض المعتقلين الى
قاعده اماراتيه للاستجواب في ارتريا في
سجون عدن والمكلف في حضرموت حدث ق روايات
متواتره ما يشبه كثيرا انتهاكات سجن ابو
غريب خلال الغزو الامريكي للعراق يقول من
استجوبتهم اي بي وهيومن رايتس واتش انهم
تعرضوا للضرب والتهديد بالقتل والاعتداء
الجنسي بما في ذلك الاجبار على التعري رفض
احد المعتقلين السابقين الخوض في التفاصيل
مكتفيا بجمله اخجل من الحديث عما تعرضت له
من انتهاكات كان يفترض ان تنقذ دول
التحالف العربي اليمن المنهك منذ ايام
صالح من انقلاب الحوثيين على الشرعيه لكن
الوقائع على الارض تقول ان كل شيء انقلب
راسا على عقب المخلص تحول الى جلاد في
ازقه مناطق سيطره الميليشيات المواليه
للامارات مراكز اعتقال وسجون سريه يقتاد
اليها وبشكل تعسفي مئ اليمنيين من قبل
افراد قوات الحزام الامني والنخبه
الحضرميه وغيرها وقصه فضاع السجون
الاماراتيه بقيه
وتداعيات ينضم الينا من مانشستر محمد جميح
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اليمني ومن جنيف
عبد الرشيد الفقيه المدير التنفيذي لمنظمه
مواطنه لحقوق الانسان مرحبا بكما وكل عام
وانتما بخير سيد عبد الرشيد الفقيه يعني
كيف ترصد التفاعل الدولي بدايه مع ما كشف
عنه من وجود سجون سريه وايضا انتهاكات تصل
لحد
شيء اولا ما كشف عنه
مؤخرا من وقائع اعتقال تعسفي واختفاء قسري
عشرات الوقائع او مئات الوقائع التي طالت
مدنيين في في المحافظات الجنوبيه هو يؤكد
الحاجه الملحه مجددا لتشكيل لجنه تحقيق
دوليه وهو ما طالبنا به وما طالبت به
المنظمات
الحقوقيه المستقله الدوليه طيله الفتره
الماضيه من اجل توثيق كافه انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان والتي بدات مع اعلان التحالف
تدخله العسكري في اليمن في 26 مارس
2015 وايضا قبلها ما فعلته جماعه الحوثي
باقتحامها للعاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء ولعدد من
المحافظات هناك وقائع مروعه لانتهاكات
حقوق الانسان طيله الفتره الماضيه مارستها
جميع اطراف الحرب ا سواء في الهجمات
الارضيه التي طالت مدنين او الهجمات
الجويه او وقائع الاعتقال التعسفي
والاختفاء القصري والوقائع المروعه
للتعذيب في السجون السريه التي كشف عنها
مؤخرا في اليمن فعليا قامت قيامه حقوق
الانسان انتهاكات واسعه في مختلف المناطق
اليمنيه غير مسبوقه نوعا وكما طالت
اليمنيين انتهاكات مروعه ينبغي ان ندعم
هذه نقاشات تشك لنه تحقيق دوليه مجد ساصل
الى هذه النقطه لجنه تحقيق دوليه ولكن هذه
الانتهاكات سيد جميح يعني الحكومه اليمنيه
سرعت وقالت ب قررت فتح يعني تحقيق عن طريق
اقامه لجنه لمتابعه هذه القضيه هل ترى بان
يعني قرار الحكومه اليمنيه ممكن تنفيذه
على ارض الواقع هل تمتلك ادوات لتنفيذه و
من سيفتح هذه التحقيق ومع
من
بعد التحيه لك وللمشاهدة
الرئاسيه ببعض التعديلات التي اجريت هنا
وهناك وكذلك يعني مما هو معروف انهم
يمنعون ايضا بعض الموالين للشرعيه في عدن
من الوصول الى اماكن عملهم كما نشرت وسائل
الاعلام في ذلك وبالتالي انا في تصوري انه
لا يمكن بحال من الاحوال ان تستطيع حكومه
الدكتور بن دغر ان تجري تحقيقا عادلا
وشفافا فيما نشر لسبب بسيط وهو انها امام
كيان موازي داخل مؤسسه الشرع
كيان موازي داخل الحكومه او خارج الحكومه
كيان موازي في اليمن لا يمكن ابدا بحال
السيطره عليه هو لا يعترف بالشرعيه اصلا
رموز هذا الكيان لا يعترفون بشرعيه الرئيس
هذه وبالتالي لن يسمح لا لبن دغر ولا
للرئيس هادي نفسه الذي منع مسؤولوه من
الوصول الى عدن او حتى من الوصول الى
حضرموت لا يمكن بحال من الاحوال ان يصل
محققون احترافي نزيه شفافون الى السجون
التي تشرف عليها هذه الميليشيات والتي
تمارس فيها اعمال لا انسانيه وبالتالي
فانه من قبيل يعني من قبيل فقط النشر
للاعلام ان الحكومه اليمنيه سوف تشكل لجنه
لفحص هذه الدعاوه هذه الحكومه لم تستطع ان
تدخل مبنى محافظه عدن كيف يمكن ان تدخل
سجنا سريا نعم هذه اسئله مطروحه وايضا
يطرح سؤال اخر لسيد الفقيه وهذه يعني عند
النقطه التي كنت تذكرها بان هذه
الانتهاكات يعني كانت ليست وليده اليوم
ولا الامس هي صر لها فتره كبيره وهي
موجوده والكل يعلم بها لماذا كل هذا الصمت
طوال هذه الفتره خاصه وان الامم المتحده
قالت الان بانها ستذهب الى فتح تحقيق بهذا
الشان في الحقيقه لا يوجد صمت لو تابعتم
عمل المنظمه الحقوقيه طيله الفتره الماضيه
وهي تعمل على هذه الانتهاكات المنظمه
الحقوق لا تعلن عن تقرير او بيان الا
حينما تكتمل شروط الفنيه والموضوعيه
للتوثيق هناك حديث مستمر منذ اشهر او منذ
بطله الثلاث سنوات المضيع حقوق الانسان في
اليمن المروعه في مختلف مناطق اليمن من
قبل مختلف الاطراف الا متحده المفوض
السامي لحقوق الانسان طالب منذ وقت مبكر
بتشكيل لجنه تحقيق دوليه لانتهاكات حقوق
الانسان وكان موقف المفوضيه السوميه لحقوق
الانسان طالب بشكل مستمر
من اجل هذه اللجنه من اجل اثبات حق الضحيا
وحاسبه المسؤولين عن ه عن هذه
الانتهاكات الحقيقه عارضت الكثير من الدول
هذه الخطوه وعلى راسها التحالف الذي تقو
السعوديه
والامارات نحن نضغط باتجاه خطوات فعاليه
ونعمل من اجل هذا ونحتاج لمسانده كل حريص
على حقوق الانسان من اجل احراز تقدم في
هذه الخطوات نحن نطالب منذ بدء الحروب
بمختلف مستوياتها في اليمن بانشاء اليه
تحقيق دوليه الامم المتحده طالبت كل
الجهات المنظمات المستقله المنظمات
الدوليه والمحليه طالبت بهذه الخطوه
عطلتها للاسف الحكومه اليمنيه و وتحالفها
الواسع الذي ساندها في مجلس حقوق الانسان
في الدوره في دورته المنعقده في سبتمبر
2015 وعطلت ايضا في
2016 واليوم ايضا نتجه الى دوره سبتمبر
2017 يفترض هذا المطلب ان يساند من قبل
جميع الحريصين عن انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
لا يمكن ان نطالب طرف من اطراف طرف منتهك
متهم بالانتهاك سواء الحكومه اليمنيه او
التحالف الداعم لها بالتحقيق في انتهاكاته
هذه لا اعتقد واختبرت طوله الفتره الماضيه
هذه هذه الاليه لم تنجح على الاطلاق ا
بالاضافه الى يعني مطالبات من قبل الامم
المتحده وخطوات ربما يعني نوايا لخطوات من
قبل الامم المتحده هناك ايضا لجنه الخدمات
المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي طلبت من
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اجراء تحقيق فوري
ايضا لكشف ملابسات الامر سيد جميح ما
اهميه مثل هذه الخطوه داخل الولايات
المتحده
الامريكيه هي خطوه مهمه بكل تاكيد يعني ان
يتبنى جون ماكين الدعوه الى اجراء تحقيق
وان يتبنى الدعوه الى اجراء تحقيق حتى مع
الذين مع المسؤولين الامريكيين الذين ذكر
انهم على علم بال بال اجراءات
التعذيب التي كانت في حضرموت وانهم
استجوبوا بعض المستجوبين من اليمنيين في
الداخل غير انهم نفوا ان يكونوا شاركوا في
التعذيب اذا هم يثبتون انهم على علم بهذه
المعلومات عن التعذيب لكنهم لم يشاركوا في
هذا التعذيب هذه الخطوه اذا ما استمر
الاعضاء الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون بتبنيها
في الكونجرس الامريكي فانها يمكن ان تشكل
عامل ضغط على اداره الرئيس ترامب الذي
للاسف الشديد كان او كانه اعطى الضوء
الاخضر
لهذه العمليات لانه عندما نتذكر اذا رجعنا
الى دعايات الانتخابيه كان يقول بانه سيجي
عمليات محدوده من تعذيب المعتقلين لانتزاع
الاعترافات وحدد مثلا الاعتراف بالايهام
بالغرق او الموت وبالتالي ربما راى الذين
يعذبون او الذين يشرفون على هذه السجون
بان هذه الاداره متساهله وتعطي اشارات
محدده بان المعذبين لن يكونوا في طائره
القانون فمضوا في ذلك اليوم نحن امام
حقائق واقعيه و على الارض نشرتها منظمات
دوليه ومنظمات وطنيه يمنيه وبالتالي الان
يتبناها ربما الكونغرس الامريكي والامم
المتحده ستدخل على الخط يجب ان لا يفلت اي
من هؤلاء الذين عذبوا اليمنيين بالنار يجب
ان لا يفلتوا من العقاب لان الحرب التي
قامت هي قامت من اجل ردع ميليشيا هذه
الميليشيا لديها سجون سريه فكيف نستبدل
هذه الميليشيا سجونها السريه بميليشيا
اخرى لديه سجون سريه هذه الميليشيا
الحوثيه ايضا قامت بعمليات تطهير مذهبي
واليوم الميليشيا التي قامت بعمليات
التعذيب قامت ايضا قبل شهور او قبل سنه
بعمليات تطهير مناطقي اذا نحن الان امام
وقائع بانه لدينا ميليشيا وجئنا ايضا
بميليشيا اخرى وهذا ما لا ينبغي ان يكون
وهذا ليس هدف التحالف العربي الذي ابرز
اهدافه والهدف الاول هو اعاده الشرعيه الى
البلاد
القي ل ان اشك سيد الفقيه في الدقائق
الاخيره سيد الفقيه الامارات نفت الامر
بمقابل منظمات عريقه اكدته من من
نصدق نصدق الضحايا سيدتي الضحايا موجودون
شهاداتهم موجوده
وموثقه الجثمان لا يكذب يمكن بافضل تقنيات
التحقيق الوصول لحقيقه ما حصل ليمنيين
وثقنا نحن في منظمه مواطنه 26 حاله تعذيب
في المحافظه الجنوبيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
احدها توفي بالغرق وفي بالغرق اريد ان
اركز فقط ان اليمن في تعز او في مارب او
في عدن او في صنعاء في كل المحافظات
تحكمها ميليشيا تمارس انتهاكات واسعه بحقق
اليمنيين ونستطيع تسليط الضوء على هذه
الانتهاكات لتخفيفها عن اليمنيين شكرا
جزيلا شكرا من جنيف عبد الرشيد الفقيه
المدير التنفيذي لمنظمه مواطنه حقوق
الانسان كما الشكر الموصول لسيد محمد جميح
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اليمني من مانشستر